الحرب في اوكرانيا ادت الى تباطؤ النشاط
الاقتصادي في اوروبا بسبب تعطيل سلاسل
التوريد وتراجع الثقام حيث يتوقع البنك
الدولي الا يسجل الاقتصاد الاوروبي اي نمو
هذه السنه وما بريطانيا فهي الدوله
الصناعيه الوحيده المرشحه للانكماش هذه
السنه كما ان اسعار الغذاء وصلت الى اعلى
مستوى لها على الاطلاق في مارس عام 2022
مع بدء العملات العسكريه ولكن الضرر
الاكبر كان الارتفاع الحاد في اسعار
الطاقه الذي ادى الى تضاعف اسعار
المستهلكين اربع مرات مقارنه بعام 20 21
ويقدر بعض الخبراء ان الحرب شطبت نقطتين
مئويتين من نمو الاقتصاد الاوروبي
يمكننا ان نقيس اثر الحرب بشكل مباشر على
فواتير الطاقه عند الذروه في بريطانيا
مثلا تكلفه الطاقه ارتفعت اربعه في المئه
في فرنسا كان رقم اقل بسبب الطاقه النوويه
ولكن في المانيا كان الرقم اعلى من
بريطانيا وبالتالي نحو نصف الارتفاع في
التضخم كان ناتجا بشكل مباشر عن الحرب
صدمه الحرب دفعت العديد من البلدان
الاوروبيه لتقليل اعتمادها على روسيا
لتحصيل الطاقه المانيا التي كانت تعتمد
على روسيا لتحصيل النصف امداداتها من
الغاز والثلث الامدادات النفطيه قامت
بتنويع مصادر الطاقه لدرجه انها لا تعتمد
اليوم على روسيا بحسب وزير الماليه
ايطاليا بدورها قلصت والدتها من الغاز
الروسي من 40% الى 25%
مع الاسف الحرب في اوكرانيا مستمره ولكن
اثر الحرب على اوروبا تتراجع لان الناس
بدات تتعايش مع غياب الغاز الروسي وحتى
اذا كان هناك ضعف في النمو هذه السنه نحن
لا نتوقع انكماشا اقتصاديا شديدا وهذا
افضل من توقعاتنا السابقه
وجدير بالذكر انه على الرغم من كل تلك
الجهود لتقليل الاعتماد على روسيا الى ان
ازمه طاقه ادت الى افلاس العديد من
الشركات والمنشات الصناعيه ضربه قاسيه
طلقات اقتصادات الدول الاوروبيه وبريطانيا
بسبب الحرب الاوكرانيه خلال السنه الماضيه
ومع استمرار الصراع العسكري تعمل تلك
البلدان على تعايش مع الواقع الجديد
ايميله ان تعود الى مسار التعافي لاحقا
هذه السنه كارينا كامل العربيه لندن